so the g20 was in Japan just a few days
ago Donald Trump was there before
heading to the North Korean DMZ but also
with him was Ivanka Trump Trump's
daughter who of course legally can't
officially be a part of Donald Trump's
administration due to anti-nepotism laws
but this hasn't stopped her from showing
up all sorts of places that she has no
business being and now a video has been
released which I'm going to play for you
from the g20 where Ivanka Trump is
speaking with some world leaders she's
in a circle small circle with Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau French
president Emmanuel macron British Prime
Minister Theresa May and head of the IMF
the International Monetary Fund
Christine Lagarde and Ivanka Trump is
there so right away there's a question
like what what the hell is Ivanka Trump
doing there and this is very visual so
if you're listening to this on the radio
or to the audio podcast find either our
YouTube clip or the video is widely
available because you really need to see
it to fully understand it the world
leaders look physically in pain when
Ivanka Trump tries to talk Christine
Lagarde looks so disgusted that Trump's
daughter is part of this discussion that
she doesn't even look over at Ivanka
when Ivanka starts saying things and
then you will see the look on Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau's face I
don't know how to describe it other than
pained and then you will see the look on
Emmanuel macron space which is I guess
what you would call a knowing smirk of
some kind that he seems to be sharing
with the other world leaders heads up
this is not safe for kids okay this is
not safe for work this is so cringy that
I recommend pulling all the kids out of
the room right away before we play it
because this is so so vile let's take a
look at it
as soon as you're talking about northern
aspect yeah a lot of people start
listening otherwise this
[Music]
as soon as you talk about normal aspect
yeah a lot of people start listening
otherwise this
[Music]
this family is embarrassing the United
States around the world everyone in this
group of world leaders is wondering what
the hell is Ivanka Trump doing here
nepotism Barbie there along with her
father the mango menace and by the way
huge huge huge props to the French
government for releasing this video
because this video is a public service
it's one of those presented without
comment things that just tells us
everything we need to know without
actually having to say anything about it
being Donald Trump's daughter is no
qualification in the sense of okay she
gets to have Trump's company when Trump
gives it up if that's what Trump wants
she gets Trump's money when he gives it
up or dies if that's what Trump wants to
do but you don't get to talk policy with
world leaders at the g20 or at least you
shouldn't and if you're a Trump is
defending this insanity step back for a
second and tell me what you'd be saying
if this was Chelsea Clinton doing this
as part of a Hillary Clinton presidency
the outrage would be nonstop 24/7 on
every single conservative media outlet
even centrist corporate media would be
hosting debate after debate over whether
this is okay or not and also to ever eat
rumpus saying it's rude for the world
leaders to be ignoring Ivanka good for
them good for them this is like when you
intern somewhere and you work your way
up as an employee for ten years and then
the boss's daughter comes in and now
she's your manager and she's clueless
two years ago Ivanka Trump was stealing
shoe designs from aqua surah and now
she's talking to prime ministers in
Japan while her dad further embarrasses
himself to every right winger who
criticized criticizes or criticized
Alexandria Casio Cortes for being quote
just a waitress before being a
congresswoman you can agree with
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez on policy or
disagree with her that's fine
at least she earned the waitressing job
herself as opposed to it being handed to
her by her family we're in serious
trouble here we're in very very serious
trouble here I want to hear from you I'm
on Instagram at Dave
Hockman the show is on instagram at
david pakman show one of today's
sponsors is impeach the card slap game
you cannot slap donald trump in real
life but you can slap him in this
hilarious fast-paced two-player card
game and you can get it for ten percent
off when you go to david pakman.com
slash impeach and use the coupon code
pakman show at checkout all one word
awesome for parties when you're having a
few drinks i've been playing it with
some friends of mine currently has a
five out of five star rating on amazon
and it combines clever satire about the
trump administration with really funny
high-quality cartoon artwork all in a
really lively card game that's easy to
learn but it stays interesting every
time you play it because of how well
designed it is and really how much
thought went into the humor and the
political commentary the game covers a
ton of themes global warming russian
collusion tax cuts for the wealthy
impeach the cards slap game is perfect
if you're looking for something fun and
casual to do with your politically
minded friends or family members you
might even learn something new about the
trump administration while you're
playing the game it's a perfect gift for
anyone who has a sense of humor about
Trump or get it for yourself and have a
really fun and witty game to play when
people come over you can even play it
tournament style get impeach the cards
slap game by going to david pakman.com
slash impeach and get 10% off when you
use the coupon code pakman show at
checkout all one word